comment je te défonce enfin tu
t'emballes non non moi je pense que je
te défonce assange peut encore revenir
aux pays-bas les bacs à cela et fatality
pas autant y aller franchement bon bah
alors fatality ou quoi mais il hésite
bien perso moi ça fait trente minutes
constate année au bout d'un moment j'en
ai marre elle c'est vrai qu'en ce
domaine est c'est physique
il n'y a pas que le physique et le
mental aussi ils vont trop loin les mecs
meira toi tu vas me cracher du feu sur
la gueule personnes crachera du feu sur
personne mais à la fin c'est bloqué ben
non non non non c'est bao au point
arrière c'est bizarre quand on pourrait
pas faire des fatalités plus soft pour
qu'on passe pour cpd street fighter non
on a tu fais trop de sentiments rien
madeira fois j'ai arraché la peau d'un
mec sympa j'ai voilà c'est de ça dont on
se parle on n'enlève pas la peau des
gens le type est déjà mort c'est un
problème éthique meetic c'est de la
surenchère du miel sur de sucre 1 après
ça les gamins n'ont plus de limites
c'est ce qu'ils devraient faire
c'est un fatalité avec un type qui se
domine l'autre avec un cours d'eau
chauffée à blanc comme ça c'est du côté
rizla du ce il faut instaurer des règles
ok on va faire au bas car être carré
quoi car duceppe croit c'est quoi c'est
un monsieur 0 oui va falloir être fort
vous avez un cancer
il vaut à six mois à venir bon bah tu
remarquez scorpions cancer on a un début
d'euro scop